[Music]
my book is called clear bright future a
radical defense of the human being and
I've written it because I think we're in
trouble
I think you'll know because it's a
philosophy festival that the
Enlightenment is a bit of a contested
idea but if we're not careful we'll just
lose it a 400-year intellectual
tradition quite easy to lose it and I
want to explain to you why I think that
it's possible and what we can do about
it there are three crises facing
developed world democracy's number one
we've got an economic system that no
longer works for enough people many
people can't see how their children have
a better life than they can those of us
in economics who study the sources of
long term growth as measured by GDP
can't see much of it
what growth there has been has been
sought from sources that are not really
sustainable in aging societies and in
already developed societies and in
societies there are already 250 trillion
dollars in debt that's the first problem
as a result of this but as a result of
other things that I want to explore with
you the second crisis is the evaporation
of consent for democracy universal human
rights and the rule of law you can see
this everywhere you go I just every week
I have a habit of trying to collect
headlines that substantiate this idea
the latest one was a piece in in did
cite the German newspaper Hungary is
lost it said civil society in the
institutions are rubble Hungary yiyu
member NATO member
and the third crisis is one I don't
think many people associate well enough
with the other two and that is the
crisis of technological control the the
the tendency of elites and states to use
the vast asymmetry of power how
to them by new information technologies
big data artificial intelligence yet to
come largely an algorithmic control very
much here the danger that they assume
control of our lives of thoughts our
behaviors at a scale not really
experienced in human history they have
the power in other words on a scale that
the Egyptian pharaohs had over some of
their subjects and if you think I'm
exaggerating just google the word
shinjang or Weger and alongside it
health check a million Chinese citizens
are being subordinated to compulsory DNA
testing compulsory health check and
minute-by-minute behavioral control in
in Inked camps that the Chinese
government has brought them into to
alter their behavior and you might think
terrible though that is in Xinjiang the
technology is already being exported to
18 in non Chinese country's population
influence technology not of course to
Britain only to Pakistan was Becca's
town Kenya economics politics technology
the three crises are linked and I think
this is the source of one of the things
that I as a journalist a new possibly in
your lives experience a lot we're living
through a period of technological
euphoria but geopolitical doom I meet
people at business conferences who are
all too ready to get the PowerPoint show
and tell you what their 10 or 15 year
technology pipeline is how they're going
to go from this to this to this 4G 5g
and then in the bar afterwards they're
all discussing the big question among
which people buy an island or accumulate
gold which is what should survival
mechanism how many guns are you going to
put on the island the two emotions are
both rational because Mike the title of
my book is non-ironic
I believe that information technology
those of you know my work I believe
information taken
oh gee gives us the ability to design a
new path beyond markets and hierarchical
based societies such as capitalism but
more than that it is Liberatore for the
human being
less work greater knowledge greater
access to knowledge less commercial
ownership of knowledge and more freedom
are all things I would argue and
implicit in information technology so
the technological euphoria for this
century is right the geopolitical Doom
is also right because in every stage of
human history we have advanced
technology in the form of hierarchical
societies that always reach a breaking
point at a certain point and those of
you know my work will know who's the
inspiration of this this assertion at a
certain point the technology clashes
with the social relations of production
copyright Karl Marx in 1858 but it's
right and that's what I think we're
living through for me as I reported
these crises morphing from the economic
crisis of 2008 through to the social
unrest of 2011 through to around 2014-15
where I think this new far-right
authoritarian misogynist racism took off
I've come to the conclusion that there
is a deeper crisis and it is what I call
in the book the crisis of the neoliberal
self that is the selves we created to
cope with the world of 30 years of
free-market economics were very good at
negotiating atomized relationships
two-dimensional non metaphoric Homo
economicus forms of activity everything
was economics neoliberalism one of the
best definitions of it is given by
William Davis the Goldsmith's University
economist who says it was the
disenchantment of politics by economics
you could replace the word
disenchantment with evisceration
everything political was reduced to
economics and therefore our behaviors
and in the book I try and sort of write
a history of how the
demonstrative behavior of states taught
us to behave like this or behaviors
adapted to everything being economics
the problem is that it worked for a
while it actually felt good the more you
adapted to acquisitive individualistic
competitive behaviors then what better
you felt and for some people life was
good the bottom half of society in the
world rolls many people in this places
like this got richer asset richer but in
2008 it stopped working
in fact it stopped working so bad that
it nearly blew up the world economy I
covered that you know close up I think I
was surprised even though I was kind of
wonder do me side of economics even
before that I was surprised by how
quickly the thing is integrated and what
I think happened is that then at that
point it became a little bit like when
that when a religion stops explaining
the world you know these old religions
you know sort of the you know the one at
a certain time on a certain day the Sun
will definitely not come up well not you
know it comes up boom end of religion um
what happens when the religion stops
explaining the world when their religion
dies in general unless some bright spark
says I've got an even better religion
than this what tends to happen is people
go well what were the old religions what
do we used to believe and you know what
we used to believe because it's back
racism white supremacy colonialism
misogyny and the worship of powerful
thieves that's back to try and explain
why why I think this happened I want to
just give you a straightforward analogy
suppose I asked you seriously to
subordinate every decision in your life
to that of an intelligent machine so the
machine can out think new the machine
can don't think any human being and it
you should run past the Machine all
decisions like should what
who should I date who should I love
where should I live where should I send
my kids to school what should the
government do and what can't the
government do supposedly until told you
that you would feel a lot better
actually if you started to anticipate
the decisions of the Machine don't go
against it in fact I would tell you that
any attempt to second-guess the machine
breaks the Machine do not at all try and
tinker with the machine just let it
decide for you the anglo-saxon version
of what I hope you would tell me it's
I'm not gonna say but but the polite
version is get lost who wants their
lives run by a machine but then suppose
I just ask you to substitute the word
market for the word machine that's the
way that's the way Friedrich Hayek
conceived at the market a spontaneous
emergent order a self rectifying machine
that can out think all human beings well
that's what we did we subordinate we
learned how to subordinate our lives to
machines either machine called the
market and the philosopher Michel
Foucault said in these amazing lectures
in the lit in the late 70s early 80s the
collège de France lectures what would
happen to us we would become
entrepreneurs of the self we did and
that we've become we will become
eminently governor ball and we did for
motivates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute's of Arts and
ideas at IAI TV
you